how do we try to identify if a thing is
living when we go to Mars when we go to
uh the different moons in our solar
system we would go outside our solar
system to look for Life yeah on other
planets it's unlikely to be a sort of a
Smoking Gun event right it's not going
to be hey I found this you don't think
so I don't think so unless you find an
elephant on some exoplanet then I can
say yeah that's there's life here no but
is there a dynamic nature to the thing
like uh it moves
it has a membrane that looks like
there's stuff inside it doesn't need to
move right I mean like look at plants I
mean they they grow but there are plants
that or can be also pretty dormant and
arguably they are the most they do
everything that is one of my
favorite professors once said that the
plant does everything that the giraffe
does without moving so the movement is
not a Zen statement necessarily but at a
certain time scale the plant does move
it just moves slower yes it moves pretty
I would I would say that and it's hard
to quantify this or even measure it but
it is a life is definitely the chemistry
finding Solutions right so it is
chemistry exploring itself
and and maintaining this exploration for
billions of years so okay so planet
is a bunch of chemistry
and then you run it and say all right
figure out what uh what cool stuff you
can come up with that's essentially what
life is given a chemistry what is the
cool stuff I can come up with if that
Makes Three
Street embarks upon are maintained in a
form of memory
right so it's this you you don't just
need to have the
uh explore exploring chemical space but
you need to also maintain a memory of
some of those solutions for over long
periods of time so that's the memory
component
makes it more living to me because
chemistry can always sample right so
chemistry is chemistry but are you just
constantly sampling or are you building
on your former Solutions and then
maintaining a memory of those Solutions
over billions of years or at least
that's what happened here chemistry
can't build life if it's always living
in the moment the physicists would be
very upset with you okay
so memory could be
a fundamental I mean life is not just
like I mean life is obviously chemistry
and physics uh leading to biology so
this is not a disciplinary
problem of one discipline trying playing
other discipline it's that but what what
you need to have is definitely a big
chemistry is everywhere right I
tend to think you can be a chemist you
can study chemistry you can study
Physics you can study geology anywhere
in the universe but this is the only
place you can study biology this is the
only place to be a biologist that's it
yeah so so definitely something very
fundamental happened here and you cannot
take biology out of the equation if you
want to understand how that vast
chemistry space of that General
sequence space got narrowed down to what
was what is available or what is used by
life you need to understand the rules of
selection and that's when Evolution and
biology comes into play so the rules of
natural selection operate to you on the
level of biology
rules I don't know if there are any
rules like that would be fascinating to
find in terms of the biology's rules
that's a very interesting and
um it's a very fascinating area of study
now and probably we will hear more about
that the decades to come but if you want
to go from the the broad to specific you
need to understand the rules of
selection and that is going to come from
understanding biology yes